u.s president joe biden and german
chancellor olav schultz sat down in the
oval office for their first white house
meeting attempting to put on a united
front
to state the obvious
germany is one of america's closest
allies
working on lockstep to further deter
russian aggression in europe biden's
statement follows weeks of criticism
that germany's been vague in its support
of nato allies schultz is also fighting
accusations he's been soft on russia as
it's amassed tens of thousands of troops
along its border with ukraine but the
biggest concern might be the issue of
nordstream 2 a contentious 11 billion
dollar natural gas pipeline being built
between germany and russia
germany relies on russia for natural gas
and even though nordstrom 2 is not yet
operational if russia invades ukraine
the u.s insists nordstrom 2 must stay
dormant but germany has been
non-committal until monday if russia
invades
that means tanks or troops crossing the
uh the border of ukraine
again then uh
there will be uh we there will be no
longer a north stream too we we will
bring an end to it will you commit today
to turning off and pulling the plug on
north stream too as i already said we
are acting together we are absolutely
united and we will not taking different
steps that answer may not be enough for
republicans and democrats in the u.s
congress who've railed against schultz
for failing to increase troops to nato
or send lethal weapons to ukraine biden
pushed back on the criticism of his
german counterpart there's no need to
win back trust he has the complete trust
of the united states
germany
is one of our most important allies in
the world there is no doubt about
germany's partnership with the united
states none the german chancellor is
expected to travel to ukraine and russia
next week to build on white house
discussions it's diplomacy aimed at
averting a russian invasion of ukraine
kimberly hellcat al jazeera the white
house